The curiosity of showing yours is,
uh,
to have,
a non national point of view,
none national editorial line,
um,
when we cover a country,
which we don't take it upon themselves
to this particular country,
but to try to take the monitor from the
neighboring countries as well.
Uh,
when we reported about bras,
says a converse it to other European
channels,
we don't take the national point of view
of what is doing for her,
for her.
This particular country are taking the
general interest of the European site
large and we try to understand if what
he's doing is good or bad.
Foster Europeans as a whole and not for
a particular country.
That is what makes you do,
is very specific in reporting about
Europe.
We present a,
both a rationale itself course,
uh,
every,
every country,
uh,
both Greece and Germany has.
There are good reasons to,
uh,
to,
act as they did a.
of course a grease is 50,
44,
having accumulated so much debt and for
her not having a put in place the
reforms as they need.
And then now try to implement a and a
converse,
these,
uh,
the fact that claim form for a bit our
trough European,
your other European countries is
natural.
It's part of the European solidarity.
And nobody can contest that.
The point of Germany is that in fact
since the other white systems,
the richest country in Europe,
there is,
I've accumulated so much support or
other European countries that are now
where it'll fit up.
And so you can also understand their
point of views.
There are countries like Greece or a
neighbor to manage their,
uh,
their own province properly,
and um,
but it is also a rupture with the
traditional,
uh,
I would say I'm a common understanding
in Germany that Germany was a support in
Europe.
Uh,
and because of its particular history,
it was a political necessity.
So also in Germany,
there are some mixed feelings about,
uh,
whether a high as a country should our
net react as Mrs Parker did.
So in your use,
of course,
we present or facets of a story
represented on screen.
You can see people shouting the streets
of attendance.
You can see,
uh,
a German leaders,
saying that Greece should set,
set out the islands in order to recover
some money,
which is absolutely a crazy idea,
but we don't say it's a crazy idea which
has to report a story every present
because we try to,
uh,
to treat the viewer as an adult.
And so to present him facts as they are
and to help him making his own
assessment of the situation,
his own judgment.
That's what,
uh,
we think,
is our remit.
And now a guitar line
is the main challenge is to,
to be simpler,
to be simple and attractive for the
viewer because I'm,
of course a national union hasn't
disappeared in Europe.
People are still very nationalist and
say they care shiftly for their own
domestic affairs.
So to make them to create a sense that's
a neighbor or fs are interesting for
them,
not only intellectually,
but also practically a if they want to
make business with neighboring countries
and also European countries,
if they want to travel to,
uh,
to,
to be altruistic reasons,
for instance,
they need to understand that the better.
So we try to make it simple and
attractive for every European watching
your used to have an eye on what to and,
and to try to,
to,
to catch a with a better understanding
of the situation abroad.
That's not easy because people,
uh,
like everywhere in the world I think.
But,
uh,
in Europe,
one could think that there is more
clarity,
feelings and is the rest of the world,
but it's not really the case.
In fact,
everybody's very nationalistic.
And so you have to create these feelings
that every,
some solidarity between people.
That's not easy.